ce sont de petites fleurs blanches et
mauve qui recouvre toute une partie du
jardin des mauvaises herbes penseront
certains mais pour françois thibert
tisaneurs le serbe a beau qui est une
plante aux vertus médicinales les
anciens l'utiliser traditionnellement
avec une cuillère d'huile de ricin pour
purger les enfants facilement
reconnaissable par son odeur
cette herbe sauvage cache encore bien
des secrets
zaba book femmes aisées babouk à cause
son lot de bouc
quand froid ça y est comme ça frotte ali
il serait le diable c'est vrai qu'un
léger le juke très connue et appréciée
aussi qu'ils en aient babou cali pousse
naturellement comme ça dans la nature un
petit grain et aux matières et des
centaines des centaines de tickets qui
poussent un peu partout
c'est vrai en abondance mais à babu qui
connut pour l'utilisation que ce soit
leurs racines que ce soit le foeil dans
les traitements de problèmes de coliques
pour les racines du bar maicon avant le
ventoux grand monde connaît ma levante
un petit graphique comme ça ils coupent
fait bouillir il boire pour les rimes à
levante et
les ababou que les petits poignée de
feuilles un petit point une feuille
petites branches comme ça il fait
briller aussi légèrement en infusion
pour de tisanes dans des préparations
pour les brûlures d'estomac babouk
brûlures d'estomac type de tisanes comme
ça pour un litre de l'eau en fusion un
quart d'heure vingt minutes je bois
alida journée pour les problèmes de
monde que d'abolir lestement utilise à
l'est aussi pour les problèmes de peau
en benzéma book utilisé pour les
problèmes de peau donc c'est un petit
plant que dans l'avenir dans certains
pays bon à la fée des crèmes pour la
peau avec sa clé vendu très cher
on a le choix soit nous mettre carrément
teese comme ça d'un grand bouteille et
puis nous mettre comme seule tige de
plantes lacets bois d'art dette que nous
met dans macération d'un bouteille ou
bien coupé coupé en petits morceaux de
compagnie bon ben on est connu pour ses
effets macération dans l'alcool pour les
douleurs pas confondre avec le branle
qu'on ne trouve plus souvent dans les
eaux de l'eure et odile différence est
nette d'un branle blanc et le branle bas
les voilà donc pareil nous couper en
petits morceaux
tout ça dans un bouteille avec d'alcool
dedans nous choisit nous quittant
l'école du match quand ils voient en a
assez des plantes dedans il verse
l'alcool dans s'était à nouveau mettre
un peu d'alcool dedans bien au cou il ya
toutes les plantes
un prêt booth et la saligue côté dance
dacquois ou ce qui fait chaud c'est au
soleil puis ne retourna lit tous les
jours un petit peu pendant quinze jours
est donc un jeu où les bons pour frotter
que douleur
on a aussi possibilité mataly comme ça
de plantes ou h & m d'un bouteilles
d'alcool pour frotter compter douleur
leaf est à peu près le même mais n'a pas
le même principe que l'arnica elie
voleur ni k way pour les douleurs
douleurs rhumatismales l arthrose peau
froide avec froide w voilà un peu